[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm linked and
I'm Rhett this week at the round table
of dim lighting we're going to be
answering your questions about anything
thank you for submitting those questions
oh yeah I love it when you guys give us
mmm stuff to stuff to talk about too but
we've got something
introspective questions we've also got
some stuff that kind of might take us
back go get a good gonna get a good
story out of you related to your
personal wife I mean personal life my
personal wife you making it public yeah
I'm making my Bret's married my wife
buff Lee and I'm just gonna give a
warning we should give them a warning
that you may pick up on a different vibe
from this your biscuit don't tell him do
you think I figure it out there's no
where they can figure it out there's
just a tremendous amount of tension
between Rhett and I that's more you can
cut it with a you could cut it with your
finger you know if you cut it with a
knife well you can cut things with a
knife but if you could cut something on
your finger then it must must be soft
that's that's just not coming together
isn't working there is no tension
between the tall one and I know it has
something to do with this conversation
happening fresh fresh off the car it's
the morning it's the it's the morning I
mean what I really just come out and
said it we're recording this in the
morning and we've never done that this
is a morning pure biscuit which seems
appropriate considering that it's a
biscuit I mean I think biscuits are
great any time of day but I think
traditionally they are enjoyed in the
morning we're just changing it up just
you know well we have a little bit more
flexibility in our schedule with the you
know with the summertime situation but
you let us know if you want us to tell
you when we're recording because no
don't tell us that I feel like I have a
little morning face for the video
Watchers I mean but you've already I
mean you've been up for a while you I
got out early you got up early you went
yeah I'm sure you do into the gym I went
oh thank you for being sure that I went
to the gym I actually did yeah
I went to the gym what time did you get
up 5:45 I got up at 5:30 oh but I woke
up at 5:00 I'm waking up before my alarm
like I think this is becoming my talent
like whenever I set my alarm because
Hallett it's not the same every day like
some days it's 5:20 some days it's 5:30
some days it's 6:30 and I'll wake up
before the alarm
each no matter what time it is you said
half an hour early that's not that's not
good timing I mean sometimes I'll know
it's now I'll be like I'll wake up it'll
be 5:25 and I supposed to get up at 5:30
I think it's just luck and if that feels
good but if I wake up a half-hour I'm
like oh man now I've got that weird
thing that's gonna happen where I look
at the clock I don't have to get up for
another thirty minutes I'm gonna go back
to sleep but it's not gonna be good so
that's what happened to me this morning
cuz now I'm thinking about I'm gonna get
into this nice cocoon spot and then the
alarms gonna go off right alright I
should just get up yeah
twenty to thirty minutes is just enough
time to get really deep into asleep
I mean that's that's the worst amount of
time to wake up before your alarm and
not get up cuz a who gets up before
their alarm that's stupid why would you
do that
mmm then I'm gonna sit on the couch and
then fall asleep sitting up because I'm
not getting ready you're what you
telling me that if you wake up early you
go and sit on the couch and wait until
the allotted time to get ready I've done
that before yeah I said well I'm gonna
do everything I do or I'll make I'll
make a coffee and I'll sit here I got 20
minutes I could drink a coffee you're
telling me that if you get up early you
don't just start the same routine it's
just a little bit early I only did it
once and clearly I was a mistake I did
it wrong I mean and I okay I apologize
routine oriented as you are I would you
can't change it up just cuz you know get
up early I didn't see I didn't I got on
waited into my allotted time right which
is the routine so I kept the routine and
that was my product you should have kept
the order and then you would just have
more time on the back end are you saying
that the gym opens at a certain time and
then you've got your space and you gotta
fill it well there are classes so I hate
showing up to the gym way early and
there's like this awkward I'm there with
the other class before they're done but
to get up out of your bed and sit on the
couch in a way I only did it once I mean
I fell back asleep I didn't go into it
wife no she's like she's like she wakes
up in the morning and here's just her
husband strangely sort of just sitting
next to the bed oh you know I didn't
just move over to the kid we have a
couch in our bedroom because that's how
we roll
are you talking about that couch I went
downstairs and I sat on like a lonesome
couch fell asleep okay makes even less
sense but usually if I wake up that that
much before my alarm clock I'll go back
to sleep but before I go to sleep I
convince myself that I'm not gonna get
up at all it's like if you give me 10
minutes or 15 minutes in my brain to
like battle out whether I'm gonna get up
or not I will not get up that's called
the resistance right the resistance I
just have to have to get up mindlessly
do you I can't get I can't engage my
brain before I get out of bed ever
snooze no because that doesn't work for
me so what happens if you snooze well I
miss the gym so that snoozing is not an
option no under any circumstances would
you if you didn't have somewhere to be
yeah I've seen it I snooze I'm not that
weird well do you think I'm a weird guy
or something snooze is part of the time
that I have allotted like it's part of
your game to snoozes is technically part
of the time every morning no I don't do
it every morning but I have to snooze
what about Jessie she's in the bed is
she already awake she gets up she's
early too I mean she gives up about the
same time it's so there's like she also
has a combination of four alarms going
off when you can count both of you
snoozing no because we have a white
noise machine that plays at a very
significant voice sounds racist okay
well you can do pink noise as well
seriously what's pink noise I'm not real
sure and there's also a brown noise so
really everybody's covered it really is
but there's brown noise pink noise and
white noise it just has to do with the
mix of frequencies I'm sorry I
but it actually not a sponsor and it
won't help anyway because I don't
remember the name of it but it's this
little octagon that has like 16
different fan sounds and then 16
different basically like fuzz like you
know frequency sounds okay and so and
it's pretty bassy and it fires the the
sound up to the ceiling so it kind of
spreads the toilet room alright it fires
that sound up so it it's emanating from
a place of a fan no it's emanating from
everywhere it feels like it's inside
your head why don't you know you have
one yes oh that's the one you have yeah
I thought that's what I thought that's
what I said I know I thought you just
said there is this thing I didn't know
that you had it no I had this isn't one
I use I'm a super light sleeper it's an
octagon
it's pretty small though I'm a super
light sleeper so I just have a fan by
the way but no because then you also
have a breeze because that blows air I
don't want what if I don't want the air
on me at that particular moment what if
he's not a air man I pegged you as a air
man I have a ceiling fan as well if I
want that I'll turn that on well you got
it covered
but the my mom has always slept with a
fan she also sleeps with my dad but she
she but she has she has a fan that is it
like your mom a fan and your dad or is
it a fan your mom and your dad fans not
in the bed the fan is but I remember
going in there it was like freaking
going into like a helipad growing up let
you go like where a helicopter was
constantly my mom ran that fan so loud
you'd like you could hear it when they
turn it on at night whose is it it
sounds like there's a baseball card in
second if it could make it could bring
gas power like I don't know how they got
such a loud fan all I know is when you
went in there you got a gas power fan in
there like if you had to go get their
attention at night like you had to knock
on the door but yeah they're like bang
on the door and then when you went in
there it was like speaking to someone in
the middle of combat it's like mom my
foot fell asleep I got news for you man
you need to read you need to just
you run this whole experience through
your mind and realize that the fan was
not to help them to sleep but it was
something it was dual purpose I do
believe that it was to cover things the
covered things that might be happening
but also my mom has always had a ringing
in her ears and so it was a way to I
guess they call it tinnitus what do they
call it tetanus yeah tonight she has a
tetanus infection yeah and so she needed
that to go to sleep I need it because
I'm such a light sleeper like I
literally will wake up if like the one
of the children like just kind of rolls
over in the next room and just makes a
noise they don't even have to yell for
us even with the white noise machine on
a lot of times I'm like Jesse Shepard is
yelling for you right now like she
doesn't know so she doesn't wake up when
my alarm my phone goes off on my side oh
god the bed it's like but any little
thing that breaks me out of the way it
was in fact the other night did the
power go off at your house no no no the
night we looked pretty close to each
other so I just I looked out and saw all
the other houses were dark too so anyway
when the white noise went off I woke up
like that's how sensitive oh so it's the
absence of white noise that almost
shocked me there's got to be an analogy
there somewhere well I'm great with
those so I'm sure I can come up with one
yeah yeah but you you use the white
noise setting not a simulated fan
setting or like a helicopter like your
mom I've used it quite makes it up I've
done a lot of different things and Jesse
don't care no she likes it she likes it
I mean I think ultimately all people
could benefit from white noise I also
think it's a little bit of a crutch so
if you don't if you don't write anyone
kind of like you don't need so even so
now when I travel I have a white noise
app I'll demonstrate
you're gonna demonstrate it yeah there
it is it's one of the ones that comes up
because I what's the app called
not a sponsor this is stream water
flowing this is what this is the best I
can get on this app because it was free
so I listened to this all night if I'm
traveling I mean I wouldn't call that
flowing I call that gushy yeah it's all
the way up man this is a I mean cuz you
can go through some other things like oh
that's that makes me want to pee
everywhere no gosh this is a cat purring
I hate that sound put it up to the mic I
want to kill that thing it actually
sounds like a cat purring in the
foreground but someone with a weed
whacker in the background do you imagine
the crazy person that needs this to
sleep okay well you're only saying that
because of your love for cats crickets
that doesn't sound like crickets it
sounds like a ring wraiths breathing
you're holding it too close to the mic
it's crazy frogs
oh wait that's creepy man like when I
would dream about cry frogs crawling on
me yeah it's like a plague
air-conditioner that's not bad in
industrial America I've never gotten
this deep I might use this one what if
what if we just record some like link
making mouth noises how crazy a freaking
grandfather clock one time I try to
sleep at my Aunt Helens house mom and
Nell sister yell alive she's like 95
years old Helen yes she she had a
grandfather clock and I was trying to
sleep in the living room I could not go
to sleep it's like a horror movie cuz
it's not a constant sound it's just like
that well it's on a rhythm
it is a pendulum I couldn't sleep it
drove me nuts I was also in a recliner
yeah that's tough anyway that's how I
get things done well see we're fresh out
of that this morning yep having a
morning biscuit fresh out the oven
fresh out the oven speaking of fresh we
got some fresh good mythical summer
stuff that you can get at mythical dot
store first thing you can get oh yeah
check this out all type of good mythical
summer merch you got to protect your
eyes with some sunglasses
check out these we're wearing them now
there's tortoise shell I got tortoise
shell and then I got the black pair and
it's got the the the mythical Rand ler
on the right temple it's got the
mythical insignia inside and then it's
got our signature signature we
definitely signed every pair of glasses
no it's an embossed we sold these last
summer they were a huge hit get you some
this summer sometimes when I'm driving
I'll wear my sunglasses over my normal
glasses like this and then you can get
the good mythical summer towel it's made
of fabric that will it's made of fabric
that will cotton which will absorb
dampness it will also provide a
beautiful sand barrier or if you're
laying out by a pool and you don't want
to touch the exposed parts of your body
where other people have touched their
exposed parts of their body you can use
the good mythical summer towel as a
barrier the good mythical summer towel
now in fabric this is look pretty cooler
right yeah you look you look like a
wouldn't hang out with me you look like
a professional poker player say my
profession that's something nobody's
done its work a full-size beach towel as
part of their get up I mean those guys
have done just about everything you know
I'm the guy with the headphones it
doesn't speak but I'm gonna be the guy
with the sunglasses in the full-size
beach towel mythical dot store support
and entertainment get a little hot
because of this fabric ok let's get to
some questions here from you we posted a
prompt on Facebook and Twitter so make
sure you're following us there if you
want to get in on this
Rachel deal know
she I recognize your name Rachel if I
were a splurge II type of person I'd
hire a maid once a month because chores
suck what is one thing that you would
like to splurge on more often and why
don't you do it hmm okay I know there's
something that I've started to splurge
on and then there's a whole other level
of splurge that I am flirting with
you're flirting with the splurge I've
started splurging on more regular
massages I think many times over the
course of conversations I've brought
this up because I never hesitate to big
up a massage and I think we talked about
this on the show but our schedules are
on each other's calendar and so when you
have a massage scheduled I see it on my
calendar and you schedule a lot of
massages and sometimes because I've got
my apple carplay situation I get in my
car and it thinks that I'm you wanting
to go get a massage and it begins
navigating to your massage sooner or
later I'm gonna show up and get in line
no you can watch I would not care like I
don't care if I'm getting massaged
anything else can be going on it won't
matter but what if I'm the one getting a
massage and you're watching not good no
that's not good at all that's what I'm
talking about doing I mean you talked
about going to gym I try to go too I try
to get up with my alarm without snoozing
and then going to the gym three or my
goal is really four times a week and I
really don't feel good about myself if I
if I only go twice and it has nothing to
do physically it's just emotionally
because I've got this standard it's but
it's mood enhancing oh absolutely
totally mood and I mean of course
everything is great about it except when
I get injured and when I get really sore
but I basically get sore every week I
don't know I guess that's a good sign is
like if you continue to workout and you
continue to give if you stop getting
sore it means you're not working out
hard enough it's because they've the
people at your gym have designed the
workouts to continue to confuse your
muscles muscle confusion is the
of the game and they know it at that gym
I used to go to your gym until I got
injured so I don't do anything meaning
your back got strained but what my
models were confused in all the best
ways so what I'm saying is
yeah you've noticed that your calendar
has a lot of my massages on it because I
put more as an incentive hey I need them
like my muscles get knotted up and so I
get very intense massages in order to be
able to go to the gym the next week and
I but psychologically I also consider it
a reward like if you go to the gym
you're four times if you meet your goal
then you've earned the right to get a
massage and pay probably way too much
money for a massage and man my pain
tolerance has gone up so much because I
just get the masseuse to go for it but I
I digress my splurge would be taking it
to the next level cuz yeah I'm already
splurging like every other week my goal
being every week I want to get a massage
my goal being every week but my splurge
would be to hire a personal masseuse do
you mean a person who is that's her only
job is to massage you or do you mean
that they just come to the office or
wherever you're well I thought that they
would come to like the house and maybe
give me a massage give Christian massage
even Lily I think because of like her
back it's a one-year anniversary of her
back fusion by the way and she's doing
fabulous hmm as of the recording of this
were celebrating today right now she was
in surgery
one year ago did you have something
special for breakfast no what we had a
special discussion about it like we
commemorated it conversationally I don't
know what kind of breakfast you would
have had you made me feel a little
guilty all of a sudden - well you made
it sound like it I mean it is a big deal
but I thought you were but it's like we
didn't do it no we
there weren't cupcakes for Brad a spine
cake for the spine cake for breakfast
but so splurging would be even so I
started thinking about that but you got
to find the right person somebody that's
really good
and then beyond that I've started to
think if I found that person and I hired
them to like show up at where I'm at
instead of me going to them even a step
further is just having that person onto
staff just literally someone following
me around is giving me a massage in
increments throughout the day can't you
over massage though I'm not such a thing
well I'd love to I'd love to have to
experience that and be able to answer
that first hand your mother that's my
goal your muscles become like veal
you know what I've just become I'm to
tenderized bright
I would like my tender pie that's what I
want to do I want to push the limits of
ten human tenderization but I do that
way it would be so ridiculous I know it
sounds ridiculous having someone because
I am not the type of person I actually I
don't like massaging people that I know
or being massaged by people I know I
don't like that I don't like this like
oh I'm gonna go up behind somebody like
a friend of mine like I've never
massaged your back you know there's some
people who live it for a video they'll
come up behind you and like massage your
back yeah I'm not into that in it
especially nowadays you gotta watch that
can't be just going up in massaging
people well yeah I don't feel like it's
but it's appropriate but I mean even
back in LA I mean it's gotta be with
consent its but but usually it's not
usually it's just like oh I'm being
massaged yeah but those weird it's just
a weird instinct there are certain
people who are massagers and they should
be masseuses and then if they're on the
payroll for that then okay it's all
legit and it's like why is it every
meeting I just want someone massaging me
while I'm in meetings like how yeah you
don't want to be that guy though you
have to think about horrible attack yeah
because he'll be back you become a
tenderized person that is constantly
being massaged now you created a social
a social awkwardness with all your
interactions you're right these are
things guy be done in secret and I ain't
that's a secret you know secret massage
in fright and I am suspicious of
becoming too tender so what's your
splurge first of all I am a splurge II
person yeah you know splurge II could be
my middle name and so
I am very often buying things for myself
but I think that the most the I don't I
think this is not in a position that
exists but I would hire a hobby hobby
Trier let me explain what this is this
is your cuz I'm sometimes I'm like you
know what a hobby try like I'd like to
paint you know I'd like to paint
I wonder what painting is like well I'd
like to go home one day and a hobby
Trier would be there he or she would say
welcome home you're good today you're
gonna try painting
I've got everything you need yeah you
know I'm saying that you don't want
someone to test the waters for you like
welcome home I've been painting all day
I'm gonna tell you what it was like oh
it's not like the person who do test the
food for the king was a cup Bearer cup
Bearer it's not a cup bear it's not a
hobby bear it's a hobby
introducer er it's somebody who is like
I've got all the equipment here it is
I've done a little research and go for
it you got one hour to see if you like
this hobby I'm gonna return all the
paints you don't open whatever because
I'm always thinking about things I want
to try but you gotta like go doc you got
to go to like Joanne's to really you
know you got to spend half a day at
Joanne's just to be ready for it
but isn't a big thing for you actually
it's all a Joanne
discovery and the spending of the money
that is part of it for you or are you
saying you don't like that part you just
want to get into it I mean I don't I
don't mind the spending of the money but
I don't think that that's what I am I
I get into things and then I buy the
things that you need to accompany the
experience but a lot of times because I
just kind of piecemeal it together I
need like I need a hobby
introducer or somebody should invent
that and be awesome business card to
anyway I'd pay for that if that if that
existed hobby introducer were there not
a not a good name they're not an expert
in anything hobby hobby guide but just
give it a shot calm no not give it a try
give it a whirl the world the world is
freedom limiting give it a whirl but in
general I'm a pretty I'm already a
splurge or so I probably don't even need
to do that here's another question now
from Meg Manuel Manuel violates a manual
[Applause]
hey you're on but go ahead I have a not
so called simple question okay for you
to if you had a chance to use anything
or become anyone in the world or the
impossible what would it be in why if we
had a chance to become the impossible
what would it be I don't know what is
anything or become anyone in the world
or the impossible basically you could do
anything and it doesn't have to be
limited to what's possible I guess
ah the thing that intrigues me is the if
you had a chance to use anything because
I immediately think about that wave pool
in Austin Texas that you were showing me
on your phone who was a Kelly Slater I
think Kelly Slater the surfer the
sessional surfer is involved if not in
in he did it I don't or he's got another
one I don't know all the facts it's a
big freaking eye I mean yeah I would say
wave pool they look at the name of that
Jacob like you're starting to think that
what would you call it automatic wave
machine Austin Texas just search that
don't think about like a waterpark wave
pool when there's like all these people
on floaties and then a horn sounds at
emerald point or whatever your waterpark
is well it's not a mini wave like on
intrusions it's not a wave pool like at
the water park and it's not a standing
wave that you see on a cruise ship where
it's just going the whole time which
that also looks fun no this is a
freaking huge pool like giant lake as
big I think it's as big as a football
field is what it looked like could be
better picture right down the centerline
of the football field not not the
halfway point what's that called
midfield midfield but bisecting the
link from goalpost to goalpost and
there's some sort of robotic apparatus
that then like travels from one end to
the other and seems to create a wave
that then you can surf on either side
you want to write a right and a left a
right and a left at the same time and if
so they can and it's a perfectly formed
I mean they can manipulate the wave but
it's a perfect tube and I want to I want
to use that any has to go there man we
got it let's just go there this summer
what's the name of it
inland surf part in the inner part in
Austin or outside Austin I bet those
dude perfect guys you've been there and
do everything knowing they're over there
in Texas just doing stuff yeah and their
big old warehouse I love LA though I'm
not gonna dog it I mean we have we have
a wave pool - it's called the Pacific
Ocean yep but it's very funny
predictable so cold and if it rains you
can't go in it for like a week
72 hours is the recommended delay
because all of the runoff from the Los
Angeles streets and whatnot go into the
old I mean it just goes into the ocean
it's just run off yeah and then you're
sitting in there and you you don't think
you're drinking it but you're drinking
it your skin is drinking it you're
digesting at least an ounce of that
water every time you go in it of course
who knows what they put in that Austin
pool probably just barbecue sauce
cowboy piss yeah a mix of those two
things but I I'm a little afraid I mean
we could we could easily make plans to
go there I mean it ain't that hard it's
not like the other thing I was gonna say
which was your personal most who's
coming he has an extra ticket well
that's on me stay out of it
he ain't masseuse in you oh it's a man
yes a man I'm just do you have an
opinion are you George Costanza
situation here do you have an opinion
about the all I care about is skills
okay so I don't care if it's a man or a
woman
I just want skills and I've I've partake
of both mmm
it doesn't matter to me it's it's a it's
like a sports deep tissue massage
there's nothing weird about it and I'm
completely naked but there's a sheet and
they know what to do with the sheet and
it's keep it on you hopefully I'm no
different than LeBron James I work out
and then I go and I get pounded on I
could it's just I could make a list of
the differences well when it comes to
getting a sports massage there's no
difference
I mean imagine how much longer it would
take I get a 90-minute massage and I'm
like dang it this is getting too short I
will not get a 60-minute anymore like I
am such I'm such a spoiled brat when it
comes to massages but if you're like how
tall is out but think about how big
LeBron James is and there's bigger
people than him that's true imagine how
long it would take to give them a proper
sports massage I mean you're I'll have
more muscles yeah
like I've got dinky muscles and it's
like think that it increases the time it
absolutely has to I don't think it's its
purport proportional to the muscle mass
of course it is I mean and you think
that LeBron James Goodell toyed is as
big as my head I guarantee you LeBron
James does not get for our massages
I got caca text him right now I gotta
bet you he's got three people on him I
don't have his number I have a fake
LeBron James that I follow on Twitter
just a fan account the other thing I was
gonna say I wanted to use was I want to
pilot the boring machine that Elan musk
has invented I want to be the guy behind
the whip like boring into the ground and
making tunnels seems boring I don't want
to do it professionally I want to do it
once all right let's do the wave machine
that's uh because that's a realistic
goal and innocent Texas man it's not
like he's on the other side of the world
right okay
maybe they'll invite us there we can
make a video that was the whole point I
guess why I didn't want to say it you
know II meant and we mentioned them
Kelly and then come on Kelly no no we
should invite rattling let us know that
was really dull boy see what happens
okay
many people said that they wanted to
hear my proposal story because we
heard your proposal story and we might
have said right even this one's from
Tamra Jackson says that we got links in
a good mythical more so oh that's really
you can you can track down the good
mythical more right where I give my
proposal story which has its it has more
than its share of uncalculated mishaps
user errors left turns user errors in in
hijinks but ended on a good way it still
took in spite of everything I did to
make contribute to engagement okay I'm
gonna tell I'm gonna do this quickly
because there's pieces to it the very
first time we ever really got to know
each other was while sitting on a bench
at macaroni grill in Cary North Carolina
waiting for Jesse to meet a locksmith
because she had locked her keys in her
car
the night before and not with you she
was not with me the night before in fact
I had only talked to her one time
however I went to like a pool party at
her parents house that my parents were
at and my brother was at and everyone
was like trying to get us together right
so like my sister-in-law was like trying
to get us together my mom wanted
everybody wanted to get us together yeah
you and so and you should explain a
little bit more of the dynamic of how
everybody knew each other but how you
didn't know her well her dad was my
dentist growing up so I knew him and
knew that he had like vaguely knew the
he had daughters but then my family and
her family started going to church
together and so that's how I actually
got to know her but you were in college
you were a sophomore right yeah I was in
college and she was a senior in high
school yeah so anyway I found out that
she was a senior in high school and I
was like well at this party no I found
out about that before like when because
when I when I met her and I talked to
her and I
liked her and then like at the end of
the conversation I find out or later I'm
talking to somebody else and they're
like yeah she's a senior has gone like
oh no no I'm in college man no and so
anyway and I was like go for it no you
weren't
don't worry just see what happens and so
I basically made up my mind that I was
like okay well I can't date this girl
she's in she's in high school and but
when I go to this this this pool thing
at her parents house I was kind of going
because I knew she was gonna be there so
it's one of these things it's like I
like this girl I can't date her but I
kind of want to know her because she
will be in college one day you know and
and so I am I'm like talking to her at
this thing and then she's like well I
gotta go I locked my keys in my car last
night up at the macaroni grill and Karie
and then Teressa my sister-in-law is
like well Rhett why don't you take her
up there why don't you drive her up
there that was Theresa mhm and then my
that's that's very Theresa yeah
definitely but the key thing is very
Jessie it's like I love the fact that
like yeah we have a we have a personal
locksmith we don't have a personal
masseuse in miles we have a personal
locksmith we have a we have like two
locksmiths on speed-dial okay yeah you
know and so this is the beat what you're
saying is this is the beginning of your
relationship and I just think it's so
poetic that this is how it began so we
drive up there from Fuquay to carry you
know 25-minute car ride and you know
we're obviously connecting like we're
having a great conversation and I'm like
how I've got this like sinking feeling
and so then we have this then the
locksmith doesn't show up for like three
hours what we sit on this bench at
macaroni grill this is before cell phone
so you couldn't call the guy he was just
like I'll be there I'll be there at 7:00
and he wasn't there until champion like
it was that kind of thing like but here
we are having this conversation on this
bench well I'm hoping he never shows up
you know what I'm saying that's pretty
cute I think he was in the bushes
watching you guys make a love connection
and he's kind of I don't I want to be
less like I want to I want to creep a
little bit be very clear that I was only
conversation it was just intense
conversation it was that you know you
had those conversations where you're
like when you're in high school you
think these are deep questions like if
you could have one superpower what would
you know I think if I could go back to
like what we actually talked about I'll
probably be like a little cringe factor
but so you don't remember that being no
I topic but you know III was making up
some questions and trying to seem
interesting you know it was working and
so we we are very interested in each
other now fast forward we did not date
while she was in high school because I
just drew a line at that did the
locksmith
I want to go deep with the locksmith he
what I don't remember anything about him
he showed up and he unlocked the car I
mean Mazda 6 to six like that it was
over not very exciting okay I say that
to let you know that the bench in front
of the macaroni grill at Carey was a
very significant location in our
relationship we did not start dating
officially until she became a freshman
in college the next year
now here but things move very quickly
mmm ridiculously quickly after that
because she went away to - she came to
Los Angeles for the summer between her
freshman and sophomore year in college
you're gonna think I'm a nut and I was
because I would never advise anyone
doing this but thank God it worked out
for us so she was going into she was
gonna be a sophomore in college and I
was gonna be I was graduating I was
graduating college yeah and so how's
that I mean that's just girl to marry me
I don't care if she's still in college I
don't care if she just finished her
freshman here in college
I love her and I want to spend the rest
of my life with her and I was married
he's working fine for me you had just
gotten married yeah yeah so I was like
why I got remarried to thanks Mary
no yeah so I married a girl who
graduated the same time as me and Greg
our other roommate got married in the
middle of the year so I was like well we
all gotta get married I got Amy over
here I got married in May he got married
in December and then you were like the
next June so but here's the proposal I
don't want to drag this out there's
other questions to get to but I was like
drag it out I I needed to get a ring so
my ring story is a little different than
yours I knew that I should probably have
a ring when I asked her so well that's
your opinion so I was thinking about
saving up oh very I didn't have any
money so I was like how am I gonna find
a ring and I'm talking to her
grandmother Gaga who's we talked about
in the book of mythicality
about how I'm trying to figure out what
to do about a ring I'm telling her whole
family I took it went out and took her
dad out to dinner and asked and asked
for his permission yes this is a very
traditional southern situation where
that kind of thing was done did he
inspect your teeth no he didn't he
already knew I had good teeth because he
was my dentist and that conversation
went well everyone knew that I was going
to ask her to marry me when she got back
and everyone was okay with it no one was
like you guys
she shouldn't she be older no one said
that I don't know if I would have
listened but no one even said that so
essentially that she was away for the
summer which is exactly the scenario
Christy was away for the summer and then
when she came back I popped the question
right so but as I'm telling Gaga this
basically following my lead emulating me
a year later to a tee except you you
learned from my mistakes exactly so
you're not saying that you wouldn't if I
hadn't done it you probably would've
made all my mistakes correct so I I'm
talking to Gaga and then she's like oh
you need a ring hold on a second and she
goes into a closet and pulls out a
freaking plastic bag of a bunch of
knickknacks
and she's like reaching down there and
she's like oh this is my this is my
mama's diamond ring and she hands me
over this giant diamond carat and a half
whoa I'm like what I was gonna get like
a third of a carat I was gonna get such
a you know and now it's gonna be pushing
it and and it was like all covered up in
some weird fitting it was like an old
setting and so I was like okay I'm gonna
pay the 250 bucks to get this thing
reset and I've got this awesome diamond
ring so I'm ready right and I didn't and
I didn't have to pay for the diamond
it's an heirloom her grandmother's name
was her great-grandmother's name was
Jesse
so she was Jesse was getting Jesse's
ring everything was falling into place
oh wow so oh wow when she gets back
about a week passes and I've got like
this special night plan where I'm gonna
pop the question and so what I ended up
doing is I was like I want to take her
to a series of locations that have been
special in our relationship and I'm
going to blindfold her in between the
locations and then I will walk her out
to this to these places and then take
the blindfold off home base oh and now
we're here and do you remember the
things that happened here pretty kinky
yeah blindfolds didn't have the quite
the same this is before 50 shades of
grey you know we didn't we weren't
familiar with that I'm still not so good
it was just just to keep someone and you
know not knowing where they're at so
trying to member all the places I took
her but I took her if you follow what
you driving her around and she had a
blindfold I was on a horse of course I
was driving her around
I didn't you get kind of nauseous with a
blindfold on she doesn't good you you
escaped you escaped another this isn't
like me this isn't like you in the book
of mythicality when the mom was taking
you to the birthday party no she was not
getting nauseous he was enjoying the
conversation and the anticipation but as
I was trying to give myself a shout-out
on instagram read em see if you follow
me there you know that I posted a
picture of the carving of our names in a
tree on NC State's campus which by at
that point the carving had only been in
a tree for about a year so
one of the stops was taking her to that
tree on NC State's campus and talking
about the memories that we had there one
was taking her to I think it was it was
a lake near NC State like Lake Johnson
or something I can't remember what it
was
sounds right but we had had like a
special date out there anyway I can't
remember all the places I took her but I
knew that the final stop was going to be
the bench in front of the macaroni grill
in Cary oh yeah and the plan was call
the locksmith winch when she takes off
the blindfold I am on one knee with this
BAM giant diamond ring that it didn't
pay for Kiko you're gonna have that BAM
you're gonna have to you know that's
good no that's good you need more Bam's
and to warn him about that needless to
say okay so yes you sat on the bench
she's blind foot keep the blindfold on
just sit down right here
she's starting to think okay this feels
like a [ __ ] okay she's starting to
guess where she yells the macaroni
yeah the guard I don't think they have
macaroni but you know she smells what
they grilled grilled macaroni and then
so like you're timing it to be like okay
now remove the blindfold okay how did it
how did he go I didn't say it in a
magician's voice I didn't do that so you
got her on the bench I got her on the
bench and then I said okay remove the
black foot and when she did I was down
on one knee with the ring and I said
something incredibly sweet that I don't
remember that ended with will you marry
me and when did something go wrong it
didn't she started crying and then she
hugged me and she did not immediately
say yes because she was smarter than you
she was 19 years old man she was a
freaking teenager she shouldn't have
said yes it was wrong but it worked out
again and what hold on she didn't say
yes no she did it wasn't like yes yes
yes he wasn't one of those situations
where you know that this is coming and
you're both were in a place in life
where it's just inevitable that you're
gonna ask the question she was surprised
like she'd there was no leak
from her grandma with a ring or her
family from permission she wasn't one of
these things where like you go pick out
the ring together yeah yeah yeah
I know that it was a surprise so but but
she still could have heard she hadn't
heard I think that she understood that
that's what I wanted but it wasn't a
very clear thing that it would it wasn't
a super surprise like what I've never
even thought about this but it was like
I did not know this was happening now
hmm but then she started nodding and I
was like is that a yes and she was like
yes and but even even after that did you
go in did you go in at that point or did
the locksmith show up at that point no
we didn't need at the macaroni grill we
just used the bench oh wow
I didn't even tip anybody did the
locksmith show up was he a part of this
that I didn't have his contact info that
would have been cool man if the
locksmiths shows up and he's he's there
slow clapping he's got the I mean you
know I mean you can find ways to improve
on my story but I'm not saying it well
the only way that I would actually
improve it's such a sweet story nothing
nothing went wrong I was I was looking
for a left turn or some sort of foible
only thing I would change is it was
super sweet very cute except because
you're wearing those sunglasses when you
tell the other thing you seem like a
complete douchebag I asked you if you
wanted me to keep these oh I know it's
like it's totally undermining your the
vibe for those watching that's gonna
have to audio again this is made
ultimately for audio but you know what
happen is they like that here at
mythical we we cut down these things so
there's gonna be just yeah isolated
story of me telling guy and they're
gonna be like what is Rhett doing that
way why is he where is he doing this
sunglass thing that'd be all the
comments are gonna be about how you're
crying under there about how Rhett must
be hiding something oh they got in a
fight no I said a black guy I think is
that the story should be that you're
hiding your emotions man well here's the
thing I'm gonna wear these sunglasses in
life from now on in everything we do
just to upset you not you well you don't
no one's upset no some people are
nobody's upset and I like upsetting
people it's my hobby
it's one of my main hobby it's not let
let's go with another question you and
Jessie are still together yeah we are
many years later hanging by a thread but
but you're doing it it's been how long
has it been it's been since that since
that proposal 18 years 18 years okay
that's crazy
another question from Zoey Sutton what
does the strangest hobby you've ever had
strangest hobby I'm sure at some point
I've talked about this great school
hobby of mine but it's so strange I just
have to I'll tell you again if you've
heard it before as a kid in in in my
road trip travels either with and I'm
talking like young like first second
third grade because I know that I'd go
on road trips with like my stepdad Jimmy
and then like my papa we would take road
trips on the interstate and we'd always
stop at at rest stops and there were or
different gas stations or whatever would
also have these like big displays of
brochures like local tourist attractions
so my hobby was collecting brochures of
places that I would most likely never
visit and then my hobby extended well
beyond that - when I got back home I
would pour over these brochures like
three three-leaf pamphlets pamphlets and
I would I had a whole stack of them you
know probably you know a foot tall worth
of brochures and I would go through them
and just look at him
we ran away about one day visiting these
places or was it about the brochure
that's as far as it was about the
brochure and it was about I would think
about visiting the places and then I
would rank them in terms of my favorite
places favorite places her favorite
brochure favorite places depicted on
brochures but the quality the brochure
did have an impact like worse
presentation you know Disney World was
on top for a while but then right behind
that you had this place called like
alligator world oh gosh yeah they had a
really good brochure they had a brochure
that was as good as Disney's brochure
maybe even better something tells me
that the actual experience of being
there was not the same at less rules
than Disney I'll guarantee you that
but there were certain points in my
reshuffling and ranking of the brochures
that alligator world did a few times
move ahead
so I was like I was like freaking Casey
Kasem in the top 40 like on a weekly
basis I would rear ank them like last
week you were at number four now you're
at number two little less entertaining
for the masses but and then when she got
to the bottom of the stack there was
like yarn shop like I would have you
know I felt threshold was pretty low oh
yeah well yeah it was all part of it
because I didn't want to leave any
brochure out I would feel guilty so
what'd you do when you went to those
things that had like 60 of them you got
one of every I I wouldn't get ones that
were like like steakhouse like there
were Steakhouse brochures I would leave
those I believe those four they do they
have the retirees they have to be
folding cuz a lot of the ones now are
just one panel yeah they would I would
never pick up a one panel it'll be like
a bifold or trifold or more more Hello
someone more MORE
how many's alligator world I believe
that was the tri-fold yeah Disney World
was big Gator that Disney World had a
lot I mean they were like I had five or
six different Disney World brochures
because they have some Steelers no you
burn them I can't think that I ever
would have burned them I just don't I
probably put them in a box at some point
and then the box was probably thrown
away when mom moved out of the house is
this why your mom used a brochure to
talk to you about sex because she knew
your I wasn't really into it no she was
not that one above alligator world it
was not in that stack so I'm gonna give
you this alligator world brochure at TG
abouts these two Gators and I'd say
what's actually happening right now
that's my weirdest hobby I think I've
had a bunch of hobbies we actually did a
whole episode about my my layers that I
call them
some people call them phases but I don't
know my weirdest one was probably bonsai
it didn't last very long it's not a
weird hobby I mean it's I mean eccentric
might be a little unexpected well it is
would you like wood but I killed the
tree and the Hobby ended and this is a
pricy tree like Jesse got this for like
a birthday present like she showed it to
me before yeah you got you get you got
it it was like it was like I was like oh
this is almost twenty years old this
required I was like Jesse this thing um
looks expensive
there were actually wasn't that pricey
he's kind of big and then I was like
yeah this type of thing requires like
like steadfast commitment for like ever
kind of left it of that that's actually
debatable it requires I could be wrong
but that's what I thought it requires
the correct the the right conditions and
so if you live in a place that doesn't
have the right conditions or you've got
it in a place that it isn't in the right
conditions then the amount of care
increases and I just didn't really
understand where it should be and I had
a book but it didn't tell me you put it
what did you do wrong you put it outside
or in the direct Sun we're supposed to
be outside a lot of them are supposed to
be outside and I believe the one but I
put it outside but it was kind of like
half cut it wasn't in full sunlight I
think maybe it should have been in full
sunlight I don't know the fact that I'm
ignorant about is the reason that I have
a dead tree do you still have it
no you put it in the green I buried it I
did it hopes funeral service for him no
you put it in the in the landscape bin
yeah I just didn't want to say that
because it seems so disrespectful boom
just landed a friend in the trash lot
that was in but to recycle to use that
probably where does a helmet every once
in a while but the thing that I'm
thinking about getting into Tai Chi what
is that that that's where the people are
doing like the slow dances by themselves
in the park and just like don't talk to
that person yeah yeah I want to be that
don't talk to that guy
no but it's like it's like karate
motions in slow motion it looks like
you're surfing on a like a yoga mat or a
blanket or just grass supposed to be
really good for like stress relief and
balance and a lot of people who are
already like into like yoga and Pilates
like what kind of naturally move into it
I've had a couple people recommend it to
me but easily confused with chai tea by
the way totally different thing you
cannot you cannot drink Taichi chai tea
while doing Taichi because it then it's
just like nothing is happening because
they cancel each other out I've seen it
happen I've seen a person completely
disappear off of the face of the earth
trying to put those two things together
it's like sine and cosine help they just
like it's sucked into a black hole of
Chi mm-hmm that's not true but I've been
thinking about that so if you if you
have any if anybody has any
recommendations any sources or tell it
should you know anything I should be
worried about the discipline of like
moving that slowly I mean I could see
how that would be very centering and
it's but it requires a lot of
concentration to not not do anything too
quickly you know because you kind of
want to get through it go through the
motions so to speak and I think you're
getting you can like conjure up energy
balls and like throw them throw them at
things so do all good um that's not true
as well Dede Haggar ADA says brainstorm
how would you get it draft at the top of
a 40-plus storey skyscraper yes not that
you should is this a team-building
exercise assignment I mean we got
engineering degrees every once in a
while I like to use them I I have an
immediate plan that comes to mind for me
well is they're dangerous first of all I
mean I recently read about the the
cinematographer who went on the the
wildlife preserve filming giraffes in
the draft swung his head around hit him
and killed him I don't think that they
heard head butted I don't think that's a
typical experiences well they said that
he wasn't following the rules that's
what the police said that the giraffe
would not be punished and he was it for
swinging his I mean that's a that's a
lot of momentum there's a restaurant and
a swing that head at the end of that
neck around
there's a restaurant in Africa where the
giraffes will stick their heads in the
windows while you're eating
hi I'm you know at the Santa Barbara Zoo
which yeah I hesitate talking about zoos
and I'd you know they're controversy
that's the last zoo that I've been to
and it may be the last do I ever go to
I'm just gonna leave it at that except
to say that while I was there I fed a
giraffe so you don't want to get into
the ethics of Zeus I don't want to get
into the ethics of Zeus I'm just saying
well saved I've read it giraffe at the
zoo in it I mean I guess it could it was
in such a way that like the it couldn't
have swung its head and killed me like
is the head of his father it's point is
the closest you could get to feed it
something and we fed it I think that's
the last experience I will have at a zoo
I bet you I can get you back into a zoo
[Music]
[Laughter]
young man lots of zoo time monsters ooh'
time left
zoo time that's gonna be a new segment I
don't know how I feel about zoos when I
was a kid I had beside my stack of
brochures I had a stack of zoo books
they were called misnomer because they
were magazines they were look they were
magazines and they were called zoo books
and each month I would get one and would
have a different animal on the cover
tastefully shot that well tastefully
photographed and I I didn't keep the
brochures but I kept all my zoo books
and I still have them and Lando looks
through them because I don't take him to
the zoo I just take him to the zoo book
says he order them and animal preference
none of my kids are as neurotic as I am
we encourage them in away from like what
the hole that I dug and and that well
that I was in the bottom of I think it's
very simple how you get a giraffe to the
top of a 40 storey skyscraper you sedate
it and you put it into like a harness
and you use a helicopter a twin-engine
well there's big Aldo hell
big elevators in like skyscrapers well
it's like look yeah if there's an
elevator that would hold the giraffe
there is I believe that there I mean if
you sedate it it's good you can curl it
up like a snake okay well let's just say
there's not an elevator like that but if
there is sure helicopter man think about
that like a droopy sleeping giraffe
beans fluffed up necks doing hey
whatever it takes if that's what that's
what the people want
that's a Twitter moment I know yeah I
also agree with the questioner this
should not actually be done we're not
suggesting it be done so if you're
thinking about if you have plans to
hoist giraffes on the top of buildings
you should probably stop that right now
I mean they would get quite a view up
there do it on green screen once you
factor in the neck and they're on top of
a skyscraper I mean that's quite a treat
for a giraffe man well which kind of
gets into the ethics of zoos I didn't
you know you went as a giraffe in the
zoo have it better than a giraffe in the
wild giraffe in the zoo is not gonna be
attacked by a lion they're just gonna
have celery shoved down their throat by
toddlers it's not I mean so much shoved
some zoos have like giant open areas I
don't know I don't actually have an
opinion about it or that I care that
much about so and and and just want to
stir the pot a little you've made people
upset by saying that that's why I was
like yeah I like you know Department the
safest I said the safest thing which was
I've been brought it up but I'm not
going to a zoo anymore
I just felt like that was the same thing
to say no no I want the people who
absolutely hate zoos to just make a
bunch of comments because I think if you
feel like it feels good for them I think
it's cathartic for them to get their
thoughts out in YouTube comments so I'm
giving them the opportunity to do that
and we can learn from it right
you shouldn't have added that last part
cuz it almost seemed sincere until you
laughed until you said the thing that
made me laugh you gotta be you gotta be
more careful
no I I was sincerely singing we can
learn from it I'm trying to do a little
PR he okay I'm spin right like you're
the one trying to be funny I'm just
trying to keep my I'm not trying to be
funny
that is never my intention I am never
trying to be funny
sunglasses again aren't helping I can't
read your face and plus you look like a
douchebag I mean the glasses look great
I think you should buy but when you're
doing a podcast in like a dimly lit room
our great-looking sunglasses that you
can purchase at mythical dot store start
to undermine your coolness no no I'm
like Joaquin men you know see what I'm
saying did you see what he's
demonstrating is the kind of thing that
Joaquin would do he would but he would
be a lot more low-key than me WWJD
Joaquin starts with a J right yeah WWJD
mm-hmm the Brit you can repurpose the
bracelets if if you're so inclined last
question
Rachel Horton if you can know the
absolute and total truth to one question
what question would you ask
I think I'd ask that giraffe at the zoo
how happy is that would that would that
would be helpful you know yeah I mean
listen I mean there's why are psychics
who say they can give that answer
I watched freaking black fishery Willie
I think watch free really I watched
blackfish and I was like I'm never going
back to SeaWorld that's wrong man what
they're doing to those freaking animals
is wrong and so they're not doing it
anymore because people stop going I'm
all for that and I know the zoos are
different but I don't think I don't
think that zoos are an equivalent just
maybe some of them are but I don't think
that most major zoos are equivalent to
SeaWorld but I don't really want to talk
about this
well that's what you said you want that
and that's why we would just like to
know yeah to the freakin speculating an
opinionated way out of our league
we would just like to ask the animals I
mean I would just I mean on that front I
guess I'd like to know I'd like to know
what my dog was thinking at any point
but I'd only get to ask one question is
that what it is this question if you can
oh absolutely truth about something you
want to know what Jade's the edge I
think yeah that's boring I think you
probably know honestly I think that the
question that I would really like to
know is I would like to know the
comprehensive definitive truth about
aliens yes so I would like to be able if
I would like do aliens exist and
describe them in details I want the
complete truth about aliens yes so to be
able to be like well actually you're the
only people in the entire universe which
would be mind-blowing or there's
actually millions of other civilizations
and let me describe them to you in this
volume this encyclopedia of alien
information like that's what I want to
know it would be nice to know but to
think about how disappointing it would
be if the answer the complete and utter
truth was the first option that there's
nothing there are no other life forms in
existence off of our planet you know boy
that would be pretty disappointing what
because I don't know if it would just if
what the answer was there well the truth
is there are there is alien life yes
tell me more as opposed to oh there's
nothing Oh seriously disappoint almost
feel like I didn't want to know you'd be
disappointing in terms of like the
personal entertainment factor the not
entertainment a fascination fascination
factor but it would be sobering and I
think it would probably make me think
differently about
lots of things really because I already
think that what we have on this earth is
being incredibly precious you know I
think that the fragile responsibility
that we have you know with the amount of
impact that we can have on earth in that
we are having on earth right now and on
our own civilization and you know we
already have a huge amount of
responsibility but if we're legitimately
the only intelligent life in the entire
universe then I think it would make me
even more that's a lot as a lot of
pressure
it'd be like hold on guys no no for real
we can't destroy this like it's actually
it's even a bigger deal that I thought
it was but if we had a complete
knowledge of alien to us life I don't
like calling them aliens I like calling
them aliens to us life thanks for
terrestrial extra Earth terrestrial yeah
they're probably terrestrial but
terrestrial means of Earth no it just
means of of dirt yeah but earth is our
dairies are again you're so
self-centered here I'm trying to get
away from that too right I'm trying to
get her eradicate Zeus really will show
up if they're not as smart as us we put
them in zoos we let all the aliens we
let all the animals out and we put
aliens in disease ah
I think sincerely I mean you you know a
complete truth about these civilizations
which probably we do not have the
capability to get to or communicate with
so that may be very frustrating but then
ultimately it would accelerate all of
our efforts to be able to make those
connections you know and then to create
an Internet of of various terrestrials
or maybe space chills I mean they all
don't have to be associated with dirt I
guess what I'm saying is if we knew that
it would accelerate our efforts to then
then that connect
and get get out of our own way we put
yeah the money that seems like a waste
of time to some people in trying to make
contact and trying to monitor the
universe and to send probes out and that
kind of thing the rate that we're
working would suddenly become the maybe
it'll happen but probably the most
important thing it would become the most
important thing unless you take like the
Stephen Hawking view which is if if
aliens exist we don't want them to know
we're here because the chances that they
are friendly are very small because if
they're anything like us whenever they
move into a new environment they destroy
everything else right put all the
animals in zoos well I have I want to
have a more hopeful approach but knowing
the truth would help or would it but
here's the thing we can't know that we
can only want to know that and now I'm
still frustrated but I think that's an
excellent answer and I think that's
where that will end this thing oh well
we'll begin the easy letdown let's begin
it okay and we can put the music in just
I forget we stop putting the music in at
the end of our podcast we should put
them which you put the easy letdown
music back in so it's in there now boy
it's feeling like this thing's coming to
a close but it's not yet ended I will
say I'm not going to wear sunglasses
next time don't do that yeah okay I mean
you don't you've already said it in the
comments cuz again listen I was at the
peak the peak experience I I would still
argue is audio only but I know that it
still impacted your ear experience
because of the way that I had to
interact with with him with those
sunglasses and even though I'm never
actually trying to be funny that's never
my motivation when I said that I was
gonna wear sunglasses this whole time it
was an attempt to be funny and I you
know I may have failed in your eyes and
I may have just annoyed you this whole
time this is a bit of a moment of growth
which gives me a little bit of pleasure
be honest with you but I'm I'm working
I'm working through that
I want to wear them again because you
out there who are annoyed by the fact
that I had them on it's what keeps me
going here I love everyone I love you
and I I think that I want you to love me
and don't don't lump me in with this guy
but I'm never trying to be funny I'm
always serious you can take everything I
say and everything that I say on this
podcast I face about at face value it's
all literal and it's never being
sarcastic
the level of that value is its
questionably attained but it's probably
low
yeah because what's it who needs sarcasm
sarcasm is nothing productive for our
world we should not be funny we should
not joke everything we say should be the
literal meaning of the words that are
coming out of our mouths because that
would just make life simpler and less
beautiful
hashtag ear biscuits is how you continue
a conversation with us on social media
please do that we value that as well as
leaving a review on iTunes it's actually
bright in here and yet yeah funny right
will speak at you next week
[Music]